hallo mein name ist luca und ich hab's
nett ich habe auf twitter mal wieder
gesagt los schickt mir doch mal ein paar
coolest netz von euch zu und ich schaue
mir die in einem video an das ist quasi
alles was ich hier machen wo was das
denn habe ich hier irgendwie ach so das
ist
wie soll ich das beste der physik kaputt
oder wieso da machen wir einfach mal
eben hier so dass unter oder müsste das
auch schon passen genau jetzt stimmt
wieder
ich habe einfach weitergebaut dick mit
farbe dass sie schon mit dem video an
das mahnmal das ist halt echt markasi
viele ankommt also ich muss jetzt noch
einmal hier wieder aktualisieren da
kommen hier schon wieder so 1000 neue
dann aktualisiere ich noch mal dann
kommen wieder zehn milliarden neue also
wir schauen jetzt erstmal yáñez ico
schickt mir bin ich jetzt im video das
auf jeden fall super das erste snap
direkt zum scheiße ist okay okay ich
mich schon wieder 1000 neue fritz hall
mein gott so ein video von one two three
fri das ist eine katze ein chat verlauf
von jesse da du hier für das video was
schickt gott ihr seid echt super was
machen angeht auch im verlauf ein bild
von simon ok was haben wir denn hier
noch alles kann irgendwer je genauer
hatte new york im namen
ich habe schon wieder da new york city
es ist irgendwie der wett
hässliches elfi oder wie ich hab gesagt
er soll mir bescheuerte bilder senden
nicht euch wie ihr hätte auch das ist
doch nicht ihr seid doch auch alle um
commander tanz jemand ballett das ja süß
gegen bieber ist es ja es ist nicht
justin bieber sondern eine erdbeere
es ist jetzt eine fusion von schnäppchen
bilder anschauen und luca malt irgendwie
was uns wach versuche ich mich ja zb hre
zu malen hübsche pero das geht jetzt an
sie geschickt vielleicht findet sich das
hier schöne so der zynische doch wie so
könnt ihr nicht einfach mal vernünftig
in die fenster schauen denn die face käm
ich meine intention die ich mache eine
blöde creme kann ich auch mal neues
video von rochow 230 2 bgb baden
screenshot gemacht was soll da als
freunde wir sind nicht im screenshot zu
machen ob jetzt 115 euro wenn ich dort
montiert jenny jenny pommer auch ihr
seid doch echt ihr bringt mich auch
immer wie ich sehe dich mal wieder humor
gotthard ist als es da denn für ein
scheiß schickte mir derart an denner
konnte aber auch irgendwie shirt kann
was ist dass sie relativ kloster
everywhere
schick mir natürlich ein tolles bild mit
einigen klos hier drauf soll das
bekommen sie dann hier geschickt die kür
dann haben wir hier die expo ritter die
diktatur um sie liegt da drumherum
da haben wir schon wieder eine
gottverdammte katze wir haben schon
wieder eine gottverdammte katze wir
haben eine kerze auf der verdammten thür
darauf eine ganze
wieder so ein experte weiß nicht ob ich
lachen oder weinen soll gleich message
ich weiß nicht ob ich lachen oder weinen
soll was sie so macht man so ein bild
luca doppel sowie sarah jakschik mir
auch drei mal ne bild nina nick nack ist
schneller da ist nina hier ich bin ne
ente anthony j
ich mag mir nicht fünf will konny
fanpage eggman bild von socken das macht
ihr könnt nicht mal richtig spielen
richtig schön macht man sowas
das ist das schielen auf den tollen
toren level war man auch hier 34 von
diesen alarm dinger niederrhein und dann
ist alles cool dass ich so eine pumpe
nacht gibt's denn irgendwelche die
einfach mal den bildhübsch gucken alle
an auge könnt ihr nicht einfach wenn ihr
euch fotografiert x mal sagen da ist
wieder die chance das ist was soll denn
das
wieso machst du einen screenshot hier
von dem wollen als abschluss jetzt noch
mal ganz schnell alle hierdurch
geballert lose luca toni ich bin braun
nannten hat halo 2 behindert dann haben
wir suite ok zum ausgleich noch ein snap
ruhig nochmal aussehe
mit roger turtle lieber an die ich
fenster die katze mal wieder dann haben
wir hier schiff brauner auf new york
city grande svp die adriana b das ist
auf jeden fall auch im einzel wie
gewesen okay wir haben hier noch ein
snap von einer das ist ein hamster
glaube ich yator schickt sich selbst in
hell und er hat auch und das gleiche
bild noch mal zum allerletzten abschluss
noch zwei videos magie war schickten
möchte mir ehrlich gesagt
zweites video mehr anschauen wenn euch
das video gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen und ich hoffe
wenn ihr das nochmal sehen wollt dann
schreibt in die kommentare
folglich snapshot ich heiße der laser
luca und dann sehen wir uns vielleicht
mal hier gibt es wieder zwei